jb a compris à partir du 3 mai +
d'attestation plus de restrictions sur
les déplacements inter régionaux c'est
bien ça et deuxième question les
pressions du président il parlait d'une
réouverture des terrasses à partir de la
mi mai donc là on parle effectivement de
la mi-mai pas seulement dû à partir de
la mi mai alors je vais être encore plus
clair même si je sais pas si c'est
possible puisque je crois l'avoir été
mais évidemment tout ce qui a été dit
par le président de la république devant
les français dans son allocution du 31
mars et la base de travail du
gouvernement et donc le 3 mai il est
prévu que les restrictions de
déplacements et donc effectivement
l'attestation l'interdiction des
déplacements inter régionaux soient
levés et que à la mi mai certaines
terrasses certains lieux de culture
rouvre et évidemment les lieux qui ont
été fermés qui sont pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux fermés depuis
maintenant un grand nombre de mois
ouvriront progressivement ensuite d'ici
à l'été au delà des restrictions de
déplacement est ce que
début mai où me mettre envisagé en tout
cas début mai pendant l' allègement du
couvre-feu première question est ce que
les mesures dont vous parlez seront
envisagées prendre des mesures
nationales ou comme le demandent
certains élus locaux notamment en
bretagne vous êtes ouvert est d'accord
pour un déconfinement et des mesures qui
pourraient être régionalisées enfin
localisé sur la première question la fin
ou l'allègement du couvre feu n'a je ne
fais pas partie des mesures dans le
président de la république a annoncé
qu'elle était mise en place pour quatre
semaines et qu'elles sachent qu'elles
sachent vais au 3 mai donc ça ne fait
pas partie de ce calendrier là et pour
le second point la territorialisation
est évidemment une option qui est
aujourd'hui sur la table dans
l'organisation et la réouverture
progressive ya pas de décision qui a été
prise sur ce sujet mais évidemment que
c'est une option sur la table parmi
d'autres